j'accueille bruno masure
[Musique]
isabelle vous avez beaucoup travaillé
ces six derniers mois vous n'avez pas du
tout disparaît le professionnellement
question très simple vous y avez suppose
beaucoup réfléchi pourquoi cette rumeur
écoutez à mon avis ce n'est pas à moi de
répondre à cette question parce que
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
étrange si vous voulez moi je suis
surtout venu ici pour pour rassurer les
gens pour leur dire pour leur dire que
je les aimais puisqu'en fait je n'ai
répondu à aucune sommation ni à aucune
convocation d'aucune sorte je ne
répondrai jamais à aucun ordre d'où
qu'ils viennent
quel qu'il soit c'est uniquement
uniquement pour rassurer public que je
suis venu ce soir et pour leur dire ne
croyez pas tout ce qui se raconte
partout parce que tout ce qui se raconte
n'est pas vrai voilà alors je vous dis
bonsoir je vous embrasse
et je vous embrasse et aussi merci
isabelle permettez moi de vous appeler
isabelle la catholique parce que vous
passez très très bien aux tubes
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
bruno masure dans sa maison près du parc
de bercy à paris
l'écrivain et vian pour et de ses chats
depuis l'âge de 25 ans ils sont toujours
succédé dans ma vie ils sont tous sdf
j'aime pas les choses trop grasses et
des troupes chichiteux est un peu snob
on va dans le dans le pigeonnier là où
je fais souvent de travailler direction
le bureau du journaliste où l'on
découvre que sa passion s'est aussi
traduite en livre
voilà mes bouquins précédent chez le
même éditeur c'était ça c'est une
commande en fait c'est un bouquin de
photos sur tout et avec des textes qui
m'ont bien amusé mais en même temps j'ai
un vrai savoir sur les sur ces bestioles
parce que parce que autant de mag loriol
les dés qu'un bouquin sur les chats et
dieu sait s'il y en a un sorte et je
m'en voyez dans sa bibliothèque un
président dont il a couvert la campagne
présidentielle tonton qui veille sur moi
et j'ai même passé 14 mois à 14 ans de
ma vie quasiment avec lui donc il doit
bien ça va continuer à surveiller et
peur et sur les étagères un objet pour
le moins insolite
est-ce que vous avez une idée du coût de
cette belle chose c'est très exactement
soixante seize mille euros autrement dit
cinq cent mille anciens francs réduit en
miettes par la broyeuse
c'est un petit objet qui a été remis à
tous ceux qui comme moi ont eu le
privilège d'assister à une petite
cérémonie organisée à bercy là tout près
au moment de la mise en place de l'euro
à l'époque tout le monde était content
c'est au milieu de ce cabinet de
curiosités que le journaliste aime
écrire ses livres la télévision surtout
à la présentation le lait la part
d'écriture est extrêmement sommaire et
donc c'est très frustrant
ce qui explique ce que beaucoup de gens
de télévision se lance dans les livres
c'est pas uniquement pour flatter leur
ego c'est que c'est une compensation de
quelque chose
bruno a maintenant rendez-vous à l'autre
bout de paris dans le 17ème
arrondissement
il organise la promotion de son tout
dernier livre le 13e
un roman dans lequel il se glisse avec
humour dans la peau de nicolas sarkozy
préférez des gens que j'aime bien ça
fait ça fait le troisième ou quatrième
bouquin qui fait chez eux
[Musique]
sarkozy qui maman attention parce que
tout ce que vous direz sera retenu
contre vous parce que j'ai un micro pg
qu'est ce que tu sais sa recontre maman
tu fais ça que j'étais ramener un livre
sex and the city
quand je dis masure là-bas à new york
quand j'ai dit mathieu ils m'ont dit ce
cat man donc et surtout connu pour les
chats c'est l'heure de la revue de
presse avec une bonne surprise
heureusement qu'elle est belle gens
parce que là franchement ça c'est sympa
strict
on a pour la promotion de son livre les
journées de bruno seront chargés zappé
ciel tu parles dimanche matin j'ai bien
alter way
que le move ce soir et demain dial rtbf
en 2014 le retour avec sainté club le
dimanche
ok merci beaucoup bon courage
salut à toutes
direction maintenant l'assemblée
nationale l'ancien présentateur du jt de
france 2 à son émission sur la chaîne
parlementaire
mais aujourd'hui il est en promo et se
retrouve invitée dans l'émission de son
ancien collègue de france 2 patrick
chêne c'est un salut patrick merci
beaucoup à vous faire marrer cette bonne
révision de l'année désormais en deux
lettres bruno masure semble être comme
un poisson dans l'eau
- de la télé et de ses plateaux et
maintenant l'alinéa se rallument sur
bruno masure bruno bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde a parlé alors
vous êtes né le 14 octobre 1947 à lille
fils d'architecte s'appelait masure être
architecte il déjà un peu cocasse oui
alors vous serez scolarisés si les curés
à saint-pierre de la 11e au bac philo
nous mêmes enfants de choeur de 8 à 14
ans et premier prix de religion
comme quoi je suis j'étais déjà droit
des faux culs pardon vous passez vos 25
premières années à lille licence de
lettres études de sciences économiques
et vous découvrez le journalisme grâce à
un mémoire de maîtrise une comparaison
entre rtl et europe 1 le but du jeu
c'était de me faire embaucher
oui mais comme j'étais petit provincial
sont sans aucune connexion dans le
milieu je pensais que sans piston n'y
arrivait pas donc j'ai contourné la
difficulté en traînant beaucoup mes
basques dans les couloirs d'europe 1 et
rtl
voilà donc vous étudiez pour savoir
laquelle est la plus pro gouvernementale
à laquelle est la plus pro us à laquelle
est la plus pro israël gras mais vous
n'entrez ni rtl ni à l'europe
vous entrez à rmc qui a troisième radio
de france
c'était sympa parce qu'à l'époque
c'était tout petit radio c'était une
radio locale ont travaillé dans une
espèce de grenier près des champs
elysées on était 14 fois c'était très
très très sympa et on faisait tout et
n'importe quoi
vous restez à rmc de 1973 à
75 mais ça vous plaît pas après
l'élection de giscard
mes chefs qui avait bien compris que
j'étais pas un militant giscardien
effréné m'ont proposé ou la porte ou de
descendre à monaco où siègent et après
avoir hésité je suis descendu un ans au
siège c'était sympa parce que j'ai
beaucoup amélioré mon ski est mon ma
technique de la régate mais je me suis
demandé ce que je prends ma retraite à
28,11 bail je suis remonté puis les
vieilles dames à monaco ce n'est pas
votre cas à l'époque non c'est là qu'un
poste qui vous correspond se libère à
tf1 vous arrivez le 1er novembre 1975
sans avoir jamais rêvé de faire de la
télévision en fait à l'époque ce n'était
pas du tout un exploit de rentrer dans
une réaction très facile voilà vous êtes
journaliste politique
vous suivez le parti socialiste et
notamment mitterrand de 1977 à 1984
vous vivez l'accession au pouvoir de la
gauche c'était très intéressant c'était
justement de suivre l'avant il après
j'ai vu la montée le passage des
apparatchiks du ps depuis leurs petits
bureaux du ps jusque où lambris dorés de
l'elysée ça c'était tout à fait
passionnant à observer d'un point de vue
humain et vous est de tous les voyages
du président mitterrand à la cité
interdite on a visité des des salles que
jamais aucun touriste ne voit on s'est
promené dans le train personnel de mao
tsé toung bon on fait on fait du
tourisme vraiment très très haut de
gamme alors à l'été 1984 vous remplacer
jean-claude bourret au jt de 20 heures
pour le week-end et en septembre vous
avez le job pour vous tout seul comme
seul émond était s'était plutôt bien
passé ils m'ont proposé le poste ainsi
qu'un passé et là vous imposer ce qu'on
appellera le style masure c'est-à-dire
d'abord l'humour et puis aussi la
hiérarchisation de l'info mais vous
dites il ya des nouvelles qui n'empêche
pas le monde de tourner quoi celui qu'il
ya des choses sur lesquelles on peut
plaisanter ou qu'on peut dire avec avec
le sourire et puis d'autres qui sont
sérieuses a changé ça un peu alors
l'humour donc et la décontraction
servier des charentais
ça faisait marrer tout le monde j'ai des
téléspectateurs qui m'ont envoyé j'en ai
brodé à mon nom par exemple mais je suis
pas fétichiste à ce point là c'était
vraiment des cadeaux et là alors
qu'aucun journal vous avez jamais
interrogé sur vos rapports avec
mitterrand quand vous présenter le
journal d'un seul coup tout le monde
veut vous interviewez quoi oui et ça
c'est j'ai découvert là la popularité
entre guillemets c'est vrai que comme
j'ai suivi mitterrand deux sur la
première chaîne là à l'époque on faisait
45 % de parts de marché et jamais aucun
journal sérieux même télérama le monde
m'a demandé comment ça se passait ce que
le l'elysée surveillent ce que vous
dites est ce qui vous engueuler quand
vous dites des choses qui sont pas tout
à fait dans la ligne et à l'ami même je
me suis retrouvé à la présentation
j'ai eu 30 demandes d'interview sur le
thème est ce que vous préférez les chats
les chiens les slips ou le caleçon la
mer où la nature est un peu décevant
quelque part vous devenez une star
système médiatique à rayssac
quelles ont été les réactions de notre
entourage ma petite femme quand je suis
rentré un jour à la maison en disant il
se peut qu'on me propose le 20 heures
elle m'a répondu avant et c'est
intéressant
ah oui donc c'est pour vous dire c'est
que voilà exactement maintenant j'ai la
chance d'être près des gens qui sont pas
du tout branché télé et qui justement
relativise très bien toute cette pseudo
gloriole avec les médias quels ont été
vos rapports pendant cette période
ce qu'est ce qui est compliqué c'est que
dès qu'on critique un peu et on a l'air
d'une mauvais coucheurs et de c'est
extrêmement pervers et les journalistes
d'une manière générale sont des gens qui
dont le métier est de critiquer les
autres
les avocats les médecins qui font des
conneries des flics tout ça mais nous on
est des intouchables
et quand on critique le travail des
journalistes on a l'air du d'humains qui
boudera
dribbles composent son camp et c'est
très agaçant vous allez gagner de
l'argent j'ai traité mon salaire quand
je suis pas quand tf1 a été privatisée à
l'époque donc c'est en 87 c'était en
france sur tf1 donc je gagnais vingt
mille francs par mois quand c'était
public et mon salaire est passé de 20
milles à 60 milles pas plus qu'on voit
là pas plus non
et l'amour ça vous a rapporté les
conquêtes amoureuses cette situation de
présentateur du journal de tf1 entend
donc clairement c'est vrai que quand on
a cette notoriété ça aide
et je soupçonne un tout petit peu mon
ami poivre d'avoir joué les
prolongations et pour 7 pour cette
raison essentiellement le meilleur
moment que cette époque c était quoi
c'était nettement quand je suivais
mitterrand parce que moi je sais c'est
beaucoup plus excitant de ce que je fais
comme reporter politique que la
présentation du journal même si c'est
beaucoup plus valorisant
valorisons mais le moi j'adorais ça en
fin de mois je suis mordu par la
politique c'est vraiment ma came
donc j'ai vécu des moments tout à fait
formidable est là aussi et plein plein
de voyage squattent parlement le plus
fort c'est quand isabelle adjani est
venu sur le plateau pour démentir la
rumeur l'annonçant mortes du sida vous
dit rien n'avait été négocié
j'étais très heureux de l'avoir mais moi
j'ai je n'avais pas vu avant on avait on
n'avait absolument rien mis au point que
la preuve c'est qu'elle s'était mise
d'accord elle voulait pas faire de promo
surtout pas le voulait pas mélanger les
genres et elle s'était mise d'accord
avec le rédacteur en chef ont dix ans
quand j'aurai quand j'estime
avoir dit tout ce que j'ai à dire je me
lèverai jus frais la bise et je m'en
irai je n'étais pas au courant
j'étais le premier ça c'était en janvier
87 et en septembre patrick poivre
d'arvor débarque au journal pour prendre
la semaine vous reléguant donc au
week-end évidemment tous les deux ces
jouets la nuit ne fonctionnent pas de la
même façon on n'a pas les mêmes amis on
fréquente pas les mêmes gens mais oui
vous le trouvez mythomane mégalomane
vous supportez pas la façon dont il
exhibe sa vie privée avant de le
reprocher à la presse notamment lors du
décès de sa fille tout ça c'est des
choses qui vous qui vous choque en fait
c'était compliqué pour moi de le dire en
public parce que j'avais l'air du du
donneur de leçons du mec qui était
jaloux parce que ils étaient plus
exposés que moi et terrain et c'est pas
parce qu'on travaille ensemble qu'on est
con doit tomber amoureux les un réseau
dans 1 dans une boîte d'assurance on
peut détester son sous-chef c'était
pareil dans une rédaction
il ya des gens à qui on s'entend bien il
ya des gens à qui on s'entend moins bien
alors en août 1990 vous donnez votre
démission de de tf1 pourquoi je me
sentais panda des coups de moins en
moins en adéquation avec la rédaction
quoi je vois la façon dont on fabriquait
le journal j'avais par moment le
sentiment d'être dans un restaurant
végétarien et d'être moi-même un
carnivore absolue comme mon boulot
c'était de vente et le menu j'étais dans
un restaurant où le venue me plaisait
pas quoi sert peut-être été un peu
schizophrénique et là ça s'est mal passé
et patrick le lay j'ai démissionné sans
demander un centime des droits des cons
parce qu'il aimerait donner de l'argent
et donc il ya eu une journée très très
rock'n'roll avec échange de deux mails
par avocat et de s'était pas les mails à
l'époque c'étaient des facs et parce
qu'il voulait pas me laisser partir
en même temps j'étais très flatté il m'a
dit texto vous êtes un élément
constitutif du fonds de commerce
donc dans sa poussette dans un ambiance
est sceptique c'est très valorisant
comme quoi il est dans l'idée qu'on est
un fonds de commerce et que quelque part
on est voilà j'étais je faisais partie
des parts de marché à laisser ça vous
partez en septembre 90 vous faites le 20
heures de france 2 vous serez virés en
alors c'est pas une éviction politique
parce qu'à l'époque j'étais j'ose pas
inquiété
premier ministre donc et pas de problème
avec vous non je pense pas
jospin m'a appelé un peu plus tard en
disant je suis désolé de ce qui vous
arrive mais je ne n'ai pas voulu
intervenir et moi j'ai trouvé ça très
très bien j'ai absolument voulu accéder
aucune sonnette
j'aurais pu parce que franchement je les
connaissais tous par coeur mais je
trouvais très bien copains me disent moi
j'en ai marre des des politiques se
mêlent des vies de la rédaction c'est
pas mon boulot je suis malheureux pour
vous je trouve ça idiot mais il était
hors de question pour moi que je
décroche mon téléphone voilà et j'ai
trouvé ça très sain alors en fait le
problème c'était votre façon de réagir à
l'info c'est à dire ça avait commencé
avec la guerre du golfe vous refusiez
les spéciales qui durait deux heures
sans info vous trouviez comment est dix
fois trop sur la mort de lady d'âge un
souvenir très malheureux de la mort de
lady d'ailleurs c'est que jamais
l'impression et notamment arlette chabot
qui était marc et attristé
elle était hystérique j'avais
l'impression que c'était sa mère qui
s'était noué tués sous le pont de l'alma
quoi et divo du calme c'est pas non plus
c'est une princesse d'opérette
elle est plus elle a pu elle est hors
circuit en angleterre elle a épousé un
arabe pas très recommandables n'y a pas
de quoi en faire des 2 kg et
effectivement on en a fait des kilos et
on a fait n'importe quoi
donc j'étais très malheureux mais
j'étais totalement marginal quoi quand
je disais ça les regarde et tous en
disant ce mec a une case en moins ou à
créer un grand mouvement - quoi la
langue après 13 ans de jt vous avez fait
tour la question vous n'étiez pas
m'accrocher à mon siège en gros c'est ce
à quoi le côté vedettes jamais été votre
calme
franchement non franchement non mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya des il ya des
moments agréables
c'est vrai quand vous quand vous
réserver dans un restaurant qui est
plein en général
vous trouve une table et vous n'êtes pas
à côté des chiottes vous êtes invités à
un tas de d'événements sympa et un tas
de démission sympa non il ya plein de
côté intéressant et valorisant
mais franchement moi quand je rentrais
dans un restaurant et que personne ne
connaissait j'étais plus heureux des
hommes
franchement c'est pas mon truc signer
les autographes c'est la journée c'est
pas mon truc
en 1998 il y aura assez pour demain un
magazine sur tf1 qui n'avait qu'un seul
numéro pourquoi parce qu'on n'a pas fait
les parts de marché on a vous effet 25%
ce qui était pas aujourd'hui ce serait
formidable
j'en ai voulu beaucoup à tf1 parce qu'on
en avait signé pour trois émissions et
son qui nous ont pas laissé notre chance
parce que l'émission franchement était
bien j'ai plein de bons souvenirs parce
que je travaillais avec vraiment une
équipe de production qui était très très
sympa qui avait vraiment beaucoup bossé
et je trouve qu'ils auraient pu nous
laisser faire les deux émissions prévues
c'était une émission qui aurait dû être
en deuxième partie de soirée n'est pas
en prime time
donc voilà mais ça c'est l'univers
impitoyable de la télé on n'a pas droit
à l'erreur
quoi alors ensuite on vous retrouve sur
le canapé de michel drucker dans
vivement dimanche prochain
alors là c'est difficile aussi parce que
vous voulez faire une revue de presse
mais comme l'émission est enregistrée le
mercredi tout ce que vous allez lire le
dimanche sur risque de tomber à plat
vous faites des poèmes j'étais un peu le
cul entre deux chaises parce que j'avais
à côté philippe delluc qui avait son
côté nombre non sens un peu absurde
comique absurde qui manie très très bien
et de l'autre côté
mon copain le psychanalyste villers et
qui lui était dans les imprécations
gauchistes c est moi je naviguais entre
les conneries et le sérieux et j'ai
jamais vraiment trouvé ma place quoi en
fait
l'or en 2002 michèle cotta vous propose
le 13 heures de france 2 vous refusez
j'avais arrêté j'avais pas envie de
replonger dans le truc surtout que
j'avais très bien compris que même leurs
idées c'était un peu de me faire jouer
le jean pierre pernaut de la deux et moi
c'est pas mon truc mais contrairement
peut-être à ce que peuvent penser
beaucoup de gens la conception de l'info
est extrêmement sérieuse mais moi je
serais un journal style monde
diplomatique si j'avais vraiment d
donc à la limite tu aurais rien sur les
faits divers donc alors qu'à 13 heures
c'est là il y en a le plus de voix
l'envers bien sûr vous dites c'est un
milieu trop carnivores pour moi moi je
suis arrivé à la télé il n'y avait que
le le fait d'être reconnu par par sa
part son vendeur de journaux
après plus on était vu qu'on gagne
d'argent donc effectivement les luttes
pour les postes étaient encore plus
saignant tour sanglante vous n'êtes pas
nostalgique alors de l'époque du journal
télévisé franchement pas je suis comme
je suis vraiment un cas mais de la
politique c'est vrai que les soirées
électorales notamment ça c'est un truc
formidable
il ya une adrénaline extraordinaire
journalistique mans c'est passionnant
parce que les armes étaient des gens qui
font la gueule votre métier qui se marre
donc c'est vrai que les sous des grandes
soirées électorales
quand je les regarde de mon canapé j'ai
un tout petit peu de nostalgie
en fait vous êtes nostalgique de
l'époque vous suiviez mitterrand non oui
oui parce qu'on à travers le monde parce
que je pense le journaliste c'est faire
du reportage j'essaie d'aller voir les
gens encore une fois présentateur c'est
vachement intéressant il ya beaucoup
davantage mais c'est du journaliste de
fonctionnaires que vous êtes vous êtes
le cul sur votre chaise toute la journée
et vous ne vivez l'actualité qu'à
travers les dépêches d'agencé
ce qui est assez réducteur lorsqu'on
prépare aussi moi je me souviens pas
j'étais de service le week-end du de la
chute du mur de berlin
j'ai janvier beaucoup mes copains qui
sont partis sans faire le sans avoir le
temps de faire leurs valises qui sont
partis à berlin pour vivre un événement
formidable et moi je restais dans ma sur
ma chaise à paris ouais vie de la
rancune contre certaines personnes
non non non franchement pas liu
beauchamp parce que vous avez désiré de
france 2 au moment où le président voilà
j'ai pas rancune j'ai une incertitude
n'a qu'une une interrogation parce que
j'ai toujours pas compris en fait ce qui
est ce qui m'a valu moi mon banc de
touche
yves albert du roy aussi aller pas là
aussi c'est une déception parce que il
est arrivé il ya un mois
il venait de télérama fin de journée au
très sérieux et nous avait fait un
discours que j'avais un taudis des
quatre mains sur le thème justement
maintenance avec la meilleure on va
arriver on va arrêter de faire du
mauvais paris match et donc est arrivé
justement la mort de lady daikin jours
après et on a fait les durées mauvais
paris match du très mauvais pari mais si
c'était à refaire alors qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas pareil ce qui a
suivi justement mon éviction
parce que c'est tombé pratiquement pile
le jour de mes 50 ans et c'est bon c'est
une date même qui vous fait gamberger
quand vous n'êtes pas complètement
crétin en plus à ce moment là j'avais
des problèmes personnels familiaux un
peu compliqué et donc ça faisait trois
événements en même temps qui fait que
j'aime pas bien vécu le truc jeu
suis resté un peu à macérer dans mon jus
et je m'en veux maintenant de ne pas en
avoir profité pour partir six mois faire
le tour du monde balade et m'aérer la
tête etc
vous regrettez de ne pas avoir essayé de
faire une autre émission un talk show je
regrette de ne pas avoir fait le tour de
des directeurs de radio parce que moi
c'est la radio qui me passionne beaucoup
plus que la télé choc la radio est un
média beaucoup plus excitant et j'aurais
dû me prendre un peu par le coût est
allé voir les directeurs de radios en
disant je suis prêt je vais ramener un
digitaux une émission un peu sympa et je
l'ait pas fait et ils sont pas venus me
chercher non plus pas je n'ai pas fait
par orgueil oui parce que peut-être
qu'effectivement quelque part dans ma
tête je me disais on va venir me
chercher un voilà est le seul qui est en
fait le seul qui est venu me chercher
c'est michel drucker pour une émission
qui en fait - correspondait par le taf
est alors le jour vous allez mourir
qu'elle voulait qu'on écrit sur votre
tombe en voyant comme j'ai fait des
poésies totalement foireuses et plus que
foireuse ce serait quelque chose du
style enfin les verts se venge
c'est très bon c'est très heureux de
rallumer la lumière cerveau mais assez
bonne à l'est pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu